[Music]
you went to high school in San Diego and
you went to the same high school that
Fast Times at Ridgemont High is based
well Cameron Crowe went to my high
school uni which is no longer there
anymore but it was he filmed part of
almost famous there and I this is just
what I heard that he based Fast Times at
Ridgemont High on his experiences at uni
and like my physics teacher was you know
mr. hand for mr. hand of quarters hand
was based on my physics teacher mr. Roth
Wow and what about Spicoli the the one
of the great characters of all time was
that how everyone talks down there he's
the archetype of everybody in my
hometown of San Diego we all I've kind
of shed it but we at the time what was
that you singing a sentence yes you
can't understand anything was that
something going wrong in your breathe
don't we artwork shoot caveman
yes hashing it out that's we San Diego
is like the cornerstone of civilization
that's where it all began
that's where all the caveman okay now I
understand as a younger man you worked
at SeaWorld what did you do at SeaWorld
I was I was that was my first job I was
15 I was a vendor I was one of the
people that walked up and down the
stadiums with churros and Pepsi you you
sold the Chur I sold the trip yes you
can and that's the worst thing to get if
you're a vendor because but here's the
thing when I was 15
puberty was not kind to me it was very
oily sweaty and it's the summer it's a
summer job and I'm wearing polyester
uniform and I they basically give you
this metal box with a stirrer no flame
in it to keep the churros hot oh yours
it's a it's it there's a flame inside
the swing yeah underneath the metal box
and it's got to be a San Diego in the
summer it's got to be 110 degree it is
the worst it is melting the box to your
polyester pants and you're and you're
hobbling up the steps and you're holding
the churro light in the churro like the
Statue of Liberty running of
yeah give us your Buller yeah yeah sure
so you're making your way up
you've got the hotbox you've got the
churro that just sounds miserable well
the worst part the worst time ever I
once got to the top and I to the top of
the steps of the stadium there was a
gentleman there were people walking
towards me they loved the churros so
they're coming to me and the son kind of
got blacked out for a moment and I
turned to look and there was a seagull
Lai coming at me and it gripped it and I
screamed it gripped on dis is churro and
I started streaming more and what were
you aiming to keep the churro get rid of
the freaking sure so that true
a rabid condor and I went to the ground
I went to the I fell with a box but I
kept half my truth I kept it but then
the sterno pour it over you burst into
flames it was horrible I'm like that's
the who's my first job that's the worst
/ best story that burns a while I love
that yeah I just loved when I got home
from work he would just like pretend to
be reading the paper I was work like I
don't care and didn't even have a paper
or was it just invisible what you're
doing dad at least have a paper when I
come in the door he was just laughs he
was just laughs and then the bird was in
the window
[Laughter]